yo what is up everybody mad Luigi here
and today I'm going to be showing you
guys my best overall generic do
everything that you possibly can do in
the game Fallout 4 built so this is
going to be based on the site of vault
111 calm if you haven't heard of it it's
a great site that's assembled a pretty
cool setup for making a character trying
out a build and seeing what perks oh you
were able to access via that build so as
you can see here this is my best build
to do everything i'm basing this build
on the ability to do experience every
part of the game that you can to the
most that you can and yes you can see i
have foreign strength foreign perception
5 and endurance 3 and charisma 6
intelligence I value that highly agility
3 luck three endurance and agility you
can take one out of both of them and
still have a pretty good best overall
generic build and if it suits more to
your play style obviously change this to
fit your play style but i think this the
best of what we currently know the place
top so i'm going to show you guys my
reasoning behind it in this little test
dummy i'm going to go through all the
special attributes and show you what
perks that you can get via using putting
a certain amount of points in the
special attribute so here i have foreign
strength mainly because armor and weapon
Smith I've value very highly as parks
because allowing to create armor and
melee weapons is what these are supposed
to these are hypothesized to be and that
is a very important perk because it's
kind of just like yeah this is kind of
this is a big part of the game armor and
making armor and weapons obviously this
is only certain part of weapons but I
think this is going to be a very a high
amount of use out of those perks next in
perception perception we're going to go
and I put foreign perception because I
want to have a lock-picking basically
blocked picking pickpocketing our main
reasons to use perception and
lock-picking is obviously a force you
need to put foreign that I've and you
don't need a perception or perk points
in lock pick and pick pocket to do it
it'll just make it a lot more easy a lot
easier and a higher
chance of success and obviously pickle
pickpocketing and lock-picking is a
important part of the game because so
much of the game so much of previews
fallouts have included those so I would
assume full up for will have that a lot
too now endurance is my second highest
skill or it can be another for I put it
because a marine boy this water skill we
don't know a lot about it if fallout 4
is going to have a lot of water gameplay
and this perk has significant impact to
that I think that you we will want to
use it for a generic build but don't
know so I'm not sure the other ones are
chem resistance like give your Leadbelly
and toughness these are all just very
important for having a tough livable
build so if you want to be tough and to
be able to survive a lot of things if
you get these purchase you're gonna be a
really strong character and be able to
survive a lot which in doing everything
i think is important because if you can
survive a lot that means you can choose
whatever you want to do and you won't
have to worry about dying as a result as
much charisma i only put in three
because in terms of the perks there are
a lot of very specific perks if you want
to do something specific in the game
then you go into charisma I think lone
wanderer is a great perk gives you a lot
of value off of the perk as you can see
here and having a little bit prisma
allows you to talk out of some
situations that you're not completely
inept at talking to people but I don't
think it's too important to have a lot
of it now over to intelligence this is
my biggest skill I put six in it because
there are a lot of important perks medic
is more help from stimpaks gun nut is
crafting mods for just guns in general
just like basic like rifles and assault
rifles and stuff like that and then
hacker is important obviously because
there should be a lot of terminals like
other Fallout games not too sure about
engineer that's more speculation and
science is somewhat a speculation but it
looks like it's going to be gun mods for
laser weaponry so like laser and
high-tech mods so I think that's very
important and also intelligence affects
the amount of XP you get so as you can
see here the more further evidence of
that people agree with me in that
intelligence if you get more
intelligence that means you're going to
get more expedient paintings which you
level up means you level up faster and
means that you can get more perks and
more special points
all of these because you can continually
put special points you don't have to
when you set choose a set of special
points you're not stuck with that you
can put it a point in another special
just like you can put a point in a perk
and I think that's really important
because it's going to allow you to do a
lot more things agility not very high
just going for this sneak because if you
don't have sneaked chances are sneak is
going to be a really almost useless
function because if you have a really
terrible sneak whenever you sneak you're
just going to be instantly seen so and I
think that's obvious that's the only
really significant needed one agility
and then luck because this is a generic
overall bill that's going looking for
consistency luck isn't really needed
that much in that fortunate finder and
scrounger do let you find a lot more
money and ammo and things like that and
bloody mess is really good for damage
and also just the X enemies exploding to
AG or red paste however it's not
especially bloody mess you especially
don't need that and then scrounger and
fortune finder you can say they are
really good so that's why I put them in
there is two and luck but because you're
going for a stable build you don't
really need that much extra stuff and
luck having making the game crazy and
stuff because you're just looking for
consistency so that's my bill I hope you
guys have enjoyed this video if you have
make sure to continue to look at my
channel for more fallout 4 content since
i will be posting a lot more of it and i
thank you for watching visa